je déclare ouvert le 76e Festival de
Cannes
[Musique]
je suis carrément et je suis actrice et
je suis à Cannes pour deux choses pour
être la maîtresse de cérémonie
d'ouverture et de clôture et aussi je
viens présenter un film argentin de
Lisandro Alonso à Cannes première
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup en ce qui me concerne
la préparation elle est beaucoup liée au
stress c'est-à-dire réussir à
dédramatiser les choses et à pas trop
penser aux côtés écrasant du du de la
salle qui est quand même une salle qui
va être remplie de gens un peu
impressionnant mais moi j'ai une chance
c'est que pour une fois enfin c'est pas
une chance dans la mine pour là ce sera
pratique c'est que j'ai pas une vue
normalement j'ai des lunettes de vue
donc je ne suis pas sûr de réussir
vraiment à distinguer les visages dans
la salle et c'est pas plus mal parce que
c'est le genre de choses je pense qu'il
pourrait m'interrompre m'interrompre
dans mon dans ma tête quoi
souvent on a tendance à dire oui les
paillettes le truc le les strass les
fêtes mais ça c'est vraiment un film par
rapport à ce qui est calme c'est la
possibilité de voir des films de pays et
de culture très différents d'avoir des
regards des différents sur le monde et
ça c'est quelque chose évidemment de moi
qui m'intéresse
[Musique]
le cinéma de toute façon on n'échappe
pas donc c'est vrai que c'est une
affaire de famille j'ai je suis venu
avec ma mère je suis venue avec mon père
j'ai vu ma mère quand j'étais enfant
j'ai vu ma mère
présentait des prix
ça me fait plaisir je trouve ça une très
belle affiche ils sont toujours très
forts en affiche d'ailleurs je trouve et
ça me fait plaisir je prends ça comme un
comment vous dire c'est une très belle
photo et ce que je trouve très beau dans
la photo c'est qu'elle nous regarde
comme ça avec ce petit sourire un petit
peu comme si elle accueillait les gens
finalement en démarche et du coup ça me
fait très plaisir